So we need to find the cube
root of negative 343.
Another way to think about this,
this is the same thing
as negative 343 to
the 1/3 power.
Or, another way of thinking
about it, if x to the third is
equal to negative 343-- so let
me write if x to the third is
equal to negative 343, then x
is equal to the cube root of
negative 343.
So these are all ways
of viewing it.
This is essentially saying,
there's some number, when I
multiply it by itself three
times, I should
get negative 343.
So let's figure out what
this number is.
And the easiest way I can think
of doing it is to do a
prime factorization of negative
343, including
factoring out the negative
numbers or a negative 1.
So if we factor out the negative
1, the first thing we
get, it's negative
1 times 343.
Let's think what other prime
numbers go into 343.
2 doesn't go into it.
This is an odd number.
3 doesn't go into it.
If you add these numbers,
it adds up to 7.
That's not divisible by 3.
That's a quick test for testing
divisibility by 3.
5 doesn't go into it.
It doesn't end with
a 5 or a 0 here.
7 is the next prime number.
Let's see if it goes into 343.
7 goes into 343-- 7 goes
into 34 four times.
4 times 7 is 28.
Subtract.
34 minus 28 is 6.
Bring down the 3.
7 goes into 63 nine times.
9 times 7 is 63.
Subtract.
We have no remainder.
So it goes in exactly
49 times.
So 343 is the same thing
as 7 times 49.
And 49 is 7 times 7.
So we can rewrite this
expression up here.
We can rewrite it as the cube
root of negative 1 times 7
times 7 times 7.
Or another way to think about
it, we could view this as
being equal to the cube root of
negative 1 times the cube
root of 7 times 7 times 7.
Now what's the cube root
of negative 1?
What number to the third power
is equal to negative 1?
Well, negative 1 to the third
power is negative 1, right?
Negative 1 times negative 1
times negative 1 is equal to
negative 1, right?
This is equal to 1.
Then times negative 1 is equal
to negative 1 again.
So that's negative 1.
And then what's the
second part?
What times itself three times is
equal to 7 times 7 times 7?
Well 7.
This is literally 7 times
itself three times.
So the second part is 7.
So the answer's going to be
negative 1 times 7, or
negative 7.
And you can verify
for yourself.
You take negative 7, multiply
it by itself 3 times.
The negative part, you could
view as just negative 1 to the
third power.
We'll end up with a negative.
And then the 7 to the third
power will give you the 343.